thank you very much indeed thank you
it's so well after a hundred years of
class days finally you get a British
speaker what took you so long did that
little disagreement of 1776 rankle so
much and why now is it because the
British election campaigns are only four
weeks long for whatever reason it is an
honor to be here and to say to the Yale
College class of 2008 you did it
you came through from all of us to all
of you congratulations well done
the invitation to a former British prime
minister to address a college which
boasts five former presidents many
former vice presidents senators too
numerous to mention is either to give me
an exaggerated sense of my own
importance or you reduce sense of yours
it was Churchill or Oscar Wilde and
there is a difference who called us two
nations divided by a common language
actually maybe in George Bernard Shaw
and and so we are but you try being in
the European Union I had an unfortunate
experience earlier my Premiership when
doing a press conference with the French
Prime Minister I speak French but not
quite as well as I thought we decided to
do the press conference live in French I
was asked whether there were any policy
positions of the French Prime Minister I
desired to emulate there is a particular
phrase in French which you must use with
care I didn't I meant to say there are
many different policies of the French
Prime Minister that I desire to emulate
what I actually said was that I desire
the French Prime Minister in many
different positions
anyway so here I'm at Yale set to come
back for the fall semester my my old
Oxford tutor was I'm afraid horrified to
hear I'd been taken on by Yale his
worries were all for Yale I may say he
said I only hope for their sake you're
going there to learn rather than to
teach now I know you Yale guys are smart
so what can I tell you that you don't
already think you know I can tell you
something in the world as I see it three
days ago in my role as Middle East then
boy I stood in the heart of Bethlehem on
one side of me lay the concrete barrier
which now separates Israel and Palestine
on the other the historic birthplace of
Jesus and the land of Palestine beyond a
few days before that I was in Jericho
and if you look up from the town center
to the left is the Mount of temptation
where Jesus spent 40 days and 40 nights
and to the right you can see Mount Nebo
where Moses looked down on the promised
land and right in front of you is the
valley of Jordan and my guy the Muslim
turned to me and said Moses Jesus
Mohammed why in god's name do they all
have to come here
but in God's name they came and for
centuries their followers have waged war
in the name of prophets whose lifework
was in pursuit of peace today though the
land that encompasses Israel and
Palestine which is small has a conflict
which symbolizes the wider prospects of
the entire vast region of the Middle
East and beyond and they're the forces
of modernization and moderation battle
with those of reaction and extremism and
the shadow of Iran looms large
what does its fake is immense will those
who believe in peaceful coexistence
triumph matching the growing economic
power and wealth with the politics and a
culture at ease with the 21st century or
will the victors be those that seek to
use that economic power to create a
politics and culture more relevant to
the feudal Middle Ages thousands of
miles from here this struggle is being
played out in the suburbs of Baghdad and
Beirut and the Gaza Strip but the impact
of its outcome on our security here and
our way of life here will register in
the core of our well-being in fact if I
had to sum up my view of the world I
would say to you turn your thoughts to
the east not just for the Middle East
but to the Far East for the first time
in many centuries power is moving east
China and India each of populations
roughly double those of America and
Europe combined and in the next two
decades those two countries together
will undergo industrialization four
times the size of the USA's and at five
times the speed we must be mindful that
as these ancient civilizations become
somehow younger and more vibrant our
young civilization does not grow old
most of all we should know that in this
new world we miss clear a path to
partnership not stand off against each
other competing for power the world in
which you in time to come will take the
reins cannot afford a return to the 20th
century struggles for hegemony the
characteristic of this world is the pace
and scope and scale of globalization
globalization is driving this change and
people are driving globalization
the consequences the world opens up its
boundaries diminish we are pushed closer
together the conclusion is that we make
it work together or not at all and the
issues that you will wrestle with the
threat of climate change food scarcity
population growth worldwide terror based
on religion the interdependence of the
world economy my student generation
would barely recognize but the
difference today is that they are all
essentially global in nature you
understand this Yale has become a
melting pot of culture and language and
civilization you are the global
generation so be global citizens each
new generation finds the world they
enter but they fashion the world they
leave so what do you inherit and what do
you pass on the history of humankind is
marked by great events but it's written
by great people people like you given
Yale's record of achievement perhaps by
you at this point incidentally I would
like to thank the seniors who invited my
son Ewan to the Yale naked parties
and I I would like to thank my son Ewan
for having refused the invitation so do
you as individuals then what wisdom of
any of Ireland first in fact keep
learning always be alive to the
possibilities of the next experience of
thinking doing and being when the Buddha
was asked near the end of his life to
describe his secret he answered bluntly
I'm awake so be awake understand
conventional wisdom but be prepared to
change it feel as well as analyze use
your instinct alongside your reason
calculate too much and you miscalculate
be prepared to fail as well as to
succeed because it is failure not
success that defines character I spent
years trying to be a politician failing
at every attempt and nearly gave up and
now you're thinking I should have
support my cockney reminded me that the
first record company the Beatles
approached rejected them as a band no
one would want to listen to be good to
people on your way up because you never
know if you will meet them again on your
way down judge someone by how they treat
those below them not those above them be
a firm friend not a fair-weather friend
it's your friendships including those
here at Yale at this time that will
sustain and enrich the human spirit you
know good test of a person is who turns
up at their funeral and with what
sincerity try not to sit the test too
early of course recently I attended a
funeral and the speaker said he would
like to begin by reading a list of all
those whose funerals he would rather
have been attending but the list was too
long it was kind of a sweet compliment
to our friend alternatively there was
Spike Milligan the quintessential
English comic who when he was asked what
he would like as the epitaph on his
tombstone replied they should write
I told you I was ill there was to
college there is a colleague of mine at
the British Parliament who once asked
another why do people take such an
instant dislike to me and got the reply
because it saves time so when you when
others think of you let them think not
with their lips but their hearts of a
good friend and a gracious acquaintance
above all however have a purpose in life
life is not about living but about
striving when you get up get up
motivated live with a perpetual sense of
urgency and make at least part of that
purpose about something bigger than you
there are great careers there are also
great causes at least let some of them
into your lives giving lifts a heart in
a way that getting never can and maybe
it really was Oscar Wilde who said no
one ever died saying if only I had one
more day at the office one small but
shocking sentence each year 3 million
children die in Africa from preventable
disease or conflict the key word
preventable when all is said and done
there is usually more said than done so
be a doer and not a commentator seek
responsibility rather than shirk it
people often ask me about leadership and
I say leadership is about wanting the
responsibility to be on your shoulders
not ignoring its weight that knowing
someone has to carry it and reaching out
for that person to be you
leaders are heat seekers not heat
deflectors and luck you have all the
luck you need you are here at Yale and
what apart from the hats could be better
and you have something else your parents
you know when you're your age you can
never imagine being our age but believe
me when you're our age we'd remember
clearly being your age that's why I'm so
careful about young men of my daughter
don't tell me what you're thinking I
know what you're thinking but there's a
parent let me tell you something about
parents despite all rational impulses
despite all evidence to the contrary
despite what we think you do to us and
what you think we do to you and yes it
is often hell on both sides the plain
unvarnished truth is that we love you
simply profoundly and utterly I remember
back in the mists of time yes the
parents you see
and you love them too Danny
I remember back in the mists of time my
dad greeting me off the train at Durham
railway station and I was a student at
Oxford Oxford and Cambridge had for
Britain kind of like Yale and Harvard
only more so so it was a big deal I've
been away from my first year and I was
coming home I stepped off the train my
hair was roughly the length of
Rumplestiltskin's and unwashed I had no
shoes and no shirt my jeans were torn
and this was in the days before this
became a fashion item worst of all we
just moved house mum had thrown out the
sitting-room drapes
I had retrieved them and made a
sleeveless long coat with them
my dad greeted me there were all his
friends at the station beside me their
kids look like Paragons of
respectability he saw the drapes he
visibly winced they did kind of stand
out so I took pity on them dad I said
there's good news I don't do drugs my
dad looked me in the eye and he said son
the bad news is if you're looking like
this and you're not doing drugs we got a
real problem so your parents look at you
today with love they know how hard it is
to make the grade and they respect you
for making it and tomorrow as I know as
a parent of one of the graduate classes
you receive your graduation their hearts
will beat with the natural rhythm of
pride pride in what you've achieved
pride in who you are they will be
nervous for you as you stand on the
threshold of a new adventure for they
know the many obstacles that lie ahead
but they will be confident that you can
surmount those obstacles for they know
also the strength of character and of
spirit that has taken you thus far so to
my fellow parents I say let us rejoice
and be glad together and to the Yale
College class of 2008 I say well done
may blessings and good fortune be yours
in all the years to come thank you very
much indeed
[Applause]